Okay, können wir anfangen?
Gerne.
Okay.
Schönen guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Cevik.
Ich bin der Diensthabendars auf der Station.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Natürlich, gerne.
Okay.
Kurz zum Ablauf.
Ich werde Ihnen jetzt ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen
und dann direkt auch zu Ihrer Beschwerde übergehen.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben oder etwas nicht verstehen,
geben Sie mir einen Zeichen.
Dann machen wir eine kurze Pause.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Schneider.
Schneider.
Wie ist Ihre Vorname?
Thomas.
Thomas Schneider.
Okay.
Und wann sind Sie genauer geboren, Herr Schneider?
Ich bin am 3. April 1970 geboren.
1970.
70.
Okay.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit?
Aktuell wiege ich 80 Kilo.
80.
Okay.
Und wie grossen Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 1,75 groß.
1,70.
Okay.
Wo wohnen Sie, Herr Schneider?
Ich wohn in Köln.
Köln.
Okay.
Und was sind Sie von beru?
Ich bin Manager.
Manager.
Sind Sie vererratet?
Herr Schneider.
Ich bin nicht vererratet, aber ich habe einen liebsten Partner.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Okay.
Welche Beschwerte haben Sie, Herr Schneider?
Also mein Problem ist, ich bin in den letzten 3 Wochen sehr müde.
Ich nehme mir mehr zu.
Ich habe einen Bauch bekommen.
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht, was los ist.
Also irgendwas stimmt mit mir nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Belegungen oder sauer Aufstoßen?
Nein.
Manchmal nicht immer.
Mein Bauch ist richtig dick geworden.
Er ist richtig so prall dick.
Er hat sich ihr Gewicht oder Appetit in letzter Zeit verändert.
Obwohl ich wenig geäste, habe ich zugenommen.
Mein Gewicht hat sich ungefähr, wie gesagt,
wie normalerweise, 75 kg.
Ich habe ungefähr 5 kg zugenommen in der letzten Zeit.
Okay.
Früher waren Sie 75 kg.
Ich war immer schlank.
Okay.
Im welches Zeitraum?
Ja, so 5, 6 Wochen vielleicht.
Okay.
Und haben Sie noch andere Beschwerte?
Zum Beispiel Übelkeit, Erbrochen, Nachtschweiß, Fieber?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Ich stört mein dicker Bauch, ehrlich gesagt.
Der ist dick und ich kriege die Hose nicht mehr zu.
Meine Patron sagt schon, was mir los sei.
Ich verstehe das alles nicht.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Konstanzation stören?
Ja, ich bin müde.
Ich kann mich nicht konzentrieren.
Ich habe fast 10 Stunden Job, den ich jeden Tag machen muss.
Ich muss Emails beantworten.
Ich muss ans Telefon gehen.
Ich muss alles machen, aber ich schaffe das nicht mehr.
Ich krieg es nicht hin.
Das kenne ich gar nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie nur Mütigkeit?
Gibt es noch andere Beschwerte?
Es ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Also ich bin nicht mehr so belastbar.
Ich kann nicht mehr viel Fahrrad fahren.
Ich bin am Wochenende oft Fahrrad gefahren.
Mit meiner Partnerin.
Aber das ist auch nicht mehr so, wie es war.
Okay.
Haben Sie vorher erkannt?
Nein.
Nein, ja.
Ich habe vorher schon mal erkannt.
Und sind Sie vollständig?
Ich bin dreimal in Covid gebt.
Einmal habe ich gehabt.
Und würden Sie sich schon einmal operieren?
Meine Mann den Sie daraus?
Meine Mann den?
Wann?
War ich noch ein Kind.
Keine Ahnung.
80er Jahre.
Okay.
Wer so eine Dexperienz hat in ihrer Familie?
Also zu meinem...
Tutte lieber.
Ich komme doch noch wieder am Ende.
Also zu meinem Vater habe ich keinen Kontakt.
Und meine Mutter, ich glaube, die hat nichts.
Keine Ahnung.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Studiang oder Wasserlassen?
Erschneider.
Nee, ich gehe alle zwei, drei Tage so.
Bei drei Tage. Einmal am zweiten.
Nee, also nicht regelmäßig.
Es ist auch weniger geworden.
Es ist ja so wie früher.
Weniger geworden.
Okay.
Und beim Wasserlassen?
Brandende Wasserlassen?
Ja.
Gibt es irgendwelche Fahrteränderungen zum Beispiel?
Immer gelb, war schon immer gelb.
Okay.
Okay. Und haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen oder beim Durchschlafen?
Ich kann mich nicht mehr gut drehen wegen meinem Bauch.
Der ist so dick geworden.
Ich kann mich nicht gut drehen.
Und ja, manchmal tut das auch weh.
Wo genau, wo steht die Schmerzen?
Genau.
Um den Gernabel überall.
Überall.
Okay. Und strahlende Schmerzen in eine andere Körperregion aus?
Nee, manchmal rücken Schmerzen auch.
Also, es ist schon blöd.
Ich muss nur Jogginghose anziehen.
Weil ich kann nur eine Jogginghose anziehen, weil die anderen Stoffrosen passten nicht mehr.
Der Gürtel geht da nicht mehr rum.
Okay.
Haben Sie das verstanden?
Könnten Sie mir bitte ein bisschen beschreiben.
Haben Sie das verstanden, was ist das?
Sie verstehen mich, ne?
Sie können nicht Gürtel benötigen oder zu machen, oder?
Ja, genau. Der geht nicht mehr.
Ja, gegen Ihre Bauchblähung oder Ihre Bauch.
Ja, der ist dick geworden einfach.
Okay. Ich habe verstanden.
Könnten Sie mir bitte ein bisschen beschreiben, Ihre Bauchschmerz?
Ja, drückend.
Drückend tut weh.
Also, als wenn jemand drauf wird.
Okay.
Und die Schmerzen steht immer in Ihrer Bauch
oder manchmal aufgetretene?
Oder?
Ist immer da.
Manchmal weniger, manchmal mehr.
Sind Sie noch da?
Da sind Sie wieder.
Es tut mir wirklich sehr leid.
Meine Zeit ist in kurzer Zeit weg.
Und deswegen leider.
Okay.
Was habe ich getratet?
Ich weiß nicht.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihre Schmerz?
Was glauben Sie denn, was das ist?
Ja, Herr Schneider, eigentlich, es ist zu früh, um etwas zu sagen.
Bevor ich Ihnen da jetzt etwas Faltes sage, würde ich abwarken,
bis ich die Untersuchungen durchgeführt habe.
Und deswegen, seien Sie bitte geduldig.
Also, mein Freund, den ich angerufen habe in den USA,
den kenne ich auch, der hat gesagt, das ist Krebs.
Nein, ich denke nicht.
Es ist sehr, ja, das ist die schlimmste Situation.
Und aber in Ihrer Familie gibt es keine Krebs.
Und natürlich müssen wir zuerst gucken.
Ich weiß ja nicht, ob mein Vater Krebs gab.
Zu ihm habe ich gar keinen Kontakt.
Ja, aber natürlich werden wir natürlich kontrollieren,
Ihre alle Werte, Blutwerte oder machen wir
die andere operative Untersuchung.
Und deswegen ist es zu früh, um etwas zu sagen.
Herr Schneider.
Okay. Und rauchen Sie, Herr Schneider?
Ziggere rauchen ich manchmal am Wochenende.
Ziggere.
Wochenende, nur Wochenende.
Ja, manchmal, wenn Freunde da sind und wenn ich ein paar Bier trinke,
dann kommt halt auch mal eine Ziggere.
Eine Ziggere, die dicken, kennen Sie vielleicht, ne?
Ja. Eine Zigaretten, die mag ich, sondern Zigaretten.
Okay. Und trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja.
Ich habe einen stressigen Beruf, ne?
Da muss man mal abschalten.
Okay.
Ungefähr zum Beispiel trinken Sie jeden Tag Alkohol.
Ja, zum Schlafen gehen braucht es schon ein bisschen was, ja.
Wein, Bier, Whiskey.
Ja.
Okay.
Und nehmen Sie bitte die Frage nicht persönlich.
Ich muss diese Frage stellen.
Hatten Sie irgendwann einmal mit dröhnem Kontakt?
Ja, klar.
In meiner Jugend, ne?
Hat jeder mal probiert, ne?
Hallo.
Hören Sie mich?
Hatten Sie...
Hören Sie mich gut, ne?
Ja, jetzt ich höre Sie.
Ja, also natürlich.
Ich habe in meiner Jugend schon mal Kontakt gehabt.
Jeder hat mal zu oben genommen, jeder hat probiert, oder?
Ja, ich habe es probiert.
Und drücken?
Das ist lange her.
Damals war es vor 30 Jahren, wo ich noch jung war.
Okay.
Und hatten Sie Fieber, Herr Schneider?
Jetzt habe ich keinen Fieber, ne?
Okay.
Ich bin müde, ich kann die ganze Zeit schlafen.
Ich kann kaum noch arbeiten.
Ich kann nicht an die Telefonen, an meine Emails, mich konzentrieren.
Ich kann nicht die Anrufe beantworten.
Das ist schon ziemlich lästig.
Es wird schon schlimm, wenn Sie das Zeitnah wieder hinkriegen würden.
Okay, haben Sie Haarausfall in letzter Zeit?
Nein.
Ich habe eh gar keine Haare.
Ich habe schon eine halbe Glatze hier.
Schon immer gehabt.
Nix Neues.
Okay.
Und sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten beckern?
Nicht bekannt.
Nicht, dass ich höre, ich bin selten beim Arzt.
Ich mag keine Ärzte.
Ich habe nicht ganz gehört.
Okay.
Ich bin selten beim Arzt.
Ich habe gar keine Zeit dafür.
Ich verstehe.
Aber jetzt müssen wir suchen, was Sie haben.
Ich muss morgen arbeiten.
Okay.
Ich habe alle meine Frage gestattet.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen, Herr Schneider?
Was habe ich denn jetzt?
Ich möchte mir etwas schauen.
Das kann das sein.
Das ist sehr schwer.
Es ist sehr schwer.
Ich habe keine Zeit dafür.
Das ist sehr schwer, etwas zu sagen.
Als Arzt haben wir immer drei Schritte.
Das Aufnahmegespräch, körperliche Untersuchungen und operative Diagnosen.
Operative Diagnosen bedeutet zum Beispiel,
Werten kontrollieren oder die andere Bildgebende Untersuchungen.
Natürlich müssen wir kontrollieren oder überprüfen.
Aber das machen Sie heute, oder?
Heute zuerst ich mache körperliche Untersuchungen und dann ich werde Blut abnehmen.
Dann nach der Blutwerte, vielleicht könnten wir zum Beispiel Darmspiegelung oder Madden-Spiegelung antworten.
Aber natürlich ist es zu früh etwas zu sagen.
Sie müssen noch eine Vorstellung haben, was ich haben könnte.
Kann das ein Krebs sein? Hab ich Krebs? Kann das sein? Was glauben Sie?
Eigentlich. Ich denke nicht, weil das nur Müdigkeit haben Sie.
Und deswegen ist Krebs normalerweise, sie haben Gewichtzunahmen.
Warum ist mein Bauch so dick geworden?
Sie könnten nur Reichstern-Syndrom haben oder andere, zum Beispiel Gastroenteritis haben, oder andere, viele Darmschleimhauten.
Und es gibt viele verschiedene Ursache. Krebs ist die schlimmste Situation.
Also der Vater von meinem Freund in den USA, der ist auch Arzt, und der hat gesagt, das könnte Krebs sein, wir müssen direkt ein CT machen.
Nein, nein, ich denke, das ist ein bisschen zu viel.
Zuerst natürlich müssen wir Ihre Blutwerte überprüfen.
Und nach der natürlichen Ergebnisse könnten wir ein bisschen mehr sprechen.
Aber ein CT machen Sie heute, ne?
CT, ja, nach der Blutwerte oder nach der körperlichen Untersuchung können wir wieder beurteilen.
Ich muss morgen wieder arbeiten. Morgen ist Montag, ich muss morgen arbeiten.
Das ist ganz wichtig, ich habe ein Projekt, das muss zu Ende laufen.
Ja, Herr Schneider, gut, dass Sie hergekommen sind.
Gesundheit ist wichtiger als alles.
Und deswegen, ich denke, versuchen Sie sich bitte entspannen.
Und natürlich, wir machen alle Untersuchungen.
Und wir kontrollieren alle Ihre Darm, Magen oder Ihre Blut.
Wir machen alles.
Und deswegen sind wir hier.
Und machen Sie sich mit der Keine Sorgen.
Wir machen alles.
Bitte machen Sie sich schnell, ich arbeite auch schnell.
Sie können ja auch schnell arbeiten.
Ich muss immer aktiv sein und muss schnell gehen.
Ja, natürlich, das ist nachvollziehbar.
Ich kann Sie gut verstehen.
Aber zuerst müssen wir natürlich Ihre Blut und Ihre Körper überprüfen.
Und jetzt gehen wir sofort.
Haben Sie denn schon eine Arbeitsdiagnose, was es sein könnte?
Haben Sie schon eine Arbeitsdiagnose, was es sein könnte?
Ja, vielleicht Schilddrühle unter Funktionen, es könnte sein,
oder Blutarmut könnte sein.
Und es gibt viele verschiedene Ursache.
Also nicht Stimme.
Also nichts Schlimmes.
Ja, natürlich.
Zuerst aber müssen wir kontrollieren.
Es ist sehr abstrüh.
Okay, dann warte ich mal ab.
Danke sehr, vielen Dank für Ihre Verständnis.
Alles klar.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Bitte.
Wie viel Trinken Sie Alkohol am Tag?
Ja, schon, ich muss runterkommen.
Ich muss schlafen, ich habe einen sehr stressigen Tag.
Und damit ich runterkomme, muss ich schon runterkommen.
Ich trink schon eine Flasche Wein schon.
Wie viel Jahre können Sie Alkohol?
Schon etwas länger.
Wie viel Jahre zum Beispiel?
5, 6.
Darf ich noch eine Frage stellen?
Ja, bitte.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente?
Nein.
Ab und zu meiner Paraziter-Mode, ich probiere, wenn ich Schmerzen habe.
Okay, danke sehr.
Sie haben gesagt, 3 Mal Covid geimpft, aber andere Impfungen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es auch oder nicht.
Das letzte Mal, wo ich beim Arzt war, war ich vor 10 Jahren.
Ich bin nicht so ein Arzt, ich mag keine Ärzte.
Sie haben gesagt, ich habe Schmerzen.
Ich habe nicht Schmerzen, aber eine Skala von 1 bis 10.
Ja, schon manchmal 7, 8 schon.
Manchmal gehen Sie wieder weg.
Wenn ich eine Paraziter-Mole über Profä nehme, aber schon 7, würde ich schon sagen.
Haben Sie geschwollene Beine?
Ein bisschen.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Haut Gelb veränderungen?
Meine Frau meinte letztens, dass meine Augen ein bisschen gelb ist.
Meine Frau meinte letztens.
Hallo, schönen guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten.
Wenn Sie Zeit hätten, würde ich mit Ihnen besprechen.
Gerne, würde ich wieder zuerst sprechen.
Herr Schneider ist 52-jährige Patient.
Der sich heute bei uns wegen seit 3 Wochen bestehende Müdigkeit
verliegt der Bauch und drückende Schmerzen im ganzen Bauch.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patient, der sich heute bei uns vorstellt.
Der Patient erwähnte, dass diese Schmerzen in den Rücken ausstrahlen.
Die Schmerzen nach Fieber, Übelkeit, Bleihung, Flöcklinie, Plexiflatulenz, Ructus, Nausea,
Emesis, alle Fragen wurden verleint.
Der Patient habe in 5 oder 6 Wochen 5 kg zugenommen.
Aber ihre Appetit sei nicht gut gewesen.
Er erklagte auch Leistungsminderung.
An Vorerkrankungen seien keiner bekannt.
Er sei vollständig geimpft.
Als Kind wurde bei Patientin Tonselektomie durchgepült.
Mit Vater habe er keinen Kontakt.
Bei Mutter gibt es keine besonderen Krankheiten.
Er nehme keine religiöse Medikamente ein.
Nur bei Bedarf, Paracetamol und Ibuprofen nehme er gegen Schmerzen.
Die Gewehr der Epidemise war unaufwählig.
Manchmal war sie durch Schlafsturungen gegen ihre Bauchbeschwerde.
Und Ihre Stuhl ist eine Frau oder ein Mann?
Herr Schneider.
Weil Sie Ihre sagen deswegen?
Ja, seine Stuhl ist in Ordnung.
Aber er geht nicht regelmäßig jeden Tag auf die Toilette.
Nur am Wochenende rauche er Ziggarete.
Und regelmäßig trinke er Alkohol am Abend.
Aber er habe nicht genau welche Alkohol benutzt.
Nur in Jugend habe er mit Drogen Kontakt.
Haben Sie ihn gefragt, ob er Alkoholiker ist?
Ja, ich habe ihn immer gefragt.
Er sagt immer gegen Arbeitsstress, trinke er regelmäßig am Abend Alkohol.
Und welche Alkohol habe ich geplagt?
Wie ist es, wie zum Beispiel Bier oder Wein?
Ich habe geplagt, aber er sagte alle Alkohol.
Ich habe ihn gefragt, ob er Alkoholiker ist.
Es gibt einen Unterschied zwischen Alkohol, trinke und Alkoholiker.
Alkohol, ja, natürlich.
Alkohol ist nichts.
Haben Sie gefragt, ob er Alkoholiker ist?
Das ist eine wichtige Frage.
Hören Sie mich?
Ich höre Sie, hören Sie mich.
Eigentlich habe ich ihn dreimal geplagt, aber leider wollte er nicht zu viel Informationen geben.
Sie haben ihn gefragt, ob er Alkoholiker ist.
Haben Sie gefragt?
Nein.
Ist er verheiratet?
Nein, er sei nicht verheiratet.
Er wohne mit seinem Lebenspartner.
Trinkt sie mit Alkohol?
Eigentlich, leider habe ich nicht gefragt.
Sie hätten fragen können, ob der Alkoholiker ist.
Oder ob jemand schon mal gesagt hat, ob er zu viel trinkt.
Manchmal wissen die Alkoholiker gar nicht, ob sie zu viel trinkt oder zu wenig.
Denken, es ist normal.
Es gibt bestimmte Fragen, die sie fragen können,
ob der Patient ein Alkoholiker ist oder nicht.
Kennen Sie diese Fragen?
Normalerweise.
Nur wenn Sie fragen, trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol,
dann haben Sie nicht bestätigt, ob das ein Alkoholiker ist oder nicht.
Und vielleicht, manche Leute möchten nicht mitteilen,
ihre Alkoholkonsum.
Genau, deswegen müssen Sie Fragen stellen.
Aber nach dieser Frage,
könnte man auch nicht mitteilen.
Richtig, das stimmt.
Aber Sie können Ihre Fragen trotzdem, das kostet er nicht.
Okay, danke sehr.
Sie können Ihre Fragen zum Beispiel,
hat Ihnen jemand schon mal gesagt, dass Sie zu viel trinken?
Oder Sie können fragen, glauben Sie, dass Sie zu viel trinken?
Oder Sie können fragen,
haben Sie schon mal überlegt, weniger zu trinken?
Wenn diese Fragen mit Ja beantwortet werden,
dann können Sie sehen, ob das ein Alkoholiker ist oder nicht.
Und oft werden die dann ein bisschen einsichtiger.
Auch wenn die am Anfang nicht das zugeben möchten.
Okay, gut.
Was glauben Sie, was der Patient hat?
Aufgrund der erwähnten Angaben gehe ich vom Verdacht auf lebensirose aus.
Aber natürlich differenziell diagnostisch kommen Hipotriose
oder Herzintubizienz in Betracht.
Zu weiteren Abkühlerungen entfehle ich Folgende Untersuchungen
für körperliche Untersuchungen.
Labour ist sehr wichtig.
Wir müssen natürlich Leberwerte oder Nierenwerte überprüfen zum Ausschluss.
Haben Sie ihn gefragt, ob er gelbe Augen hat
oder ob er eine gelb verferbene Haut hat?
Hallo.
Können Sie mich hören?
Hallo, hören Sie mich?
Ich höre Sie, hören Sie mich auch?
Super, ich konnte nicht Sie hören.
Haben Sie ihn gefragt, ob er eine Gelbverfärbung der Augen hat,
ob er ein Äkterus hat?
Leider, ich habe ihn nicht gefragt.
Das ist eine sehr wichtige Frage.
Warum glauben Sie, dass ein Dick in Bauch hat?
Woher kommt das?
Es könnte Acid sein.
Wenn der Patient Herz-Unsphyzias hat,
könnte es auch Acid, geschwollene Beine oder pleurale Ephysiöne sein.
Zum Ausschluss von Herz-Unsphyzias
muss man pro BMP oder BMP überprüfen.
Was machen Sie als Erstes bei der Ambulanz?
Natürlich müssen wir Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, kleine Blutbild überprüfen.
Was können Sie auch machen in der Ambulanz?
Was sollten Sie machen?
Abdominal-Ultraschalen müssen wir zuerst überprüfen.
Wenn uns die Ergebnisse vorliegen,
können wir weitere Untersuchungen antworten.
Welche weiteren Untersuchungen?
Was können Sie auch machen?
Ultraschalen und ZT.
Was können Sie auch machen, wenn es Ultraschalen ist?
Blut, Urin, körperliche Untersuchungen, Ultraschalen.
Und eine Untersuchung können Sie auch machen.
Was können Sie auch machen?
Was müssen Sie denn auch machen?
Im Darm- oder Magelspiel gehen?
Nicht in der Ambulanz.
Sie können punktieren.
Sie können Acid es punktieren und entlasten.
Aber wenn es Acid gibt,
dann können Sie es auch machen.
Aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass Acid es ist, ist groß.
Ich habe gemeint,
dass es Acid gibt.
Wenn es Acid es geben sollte,
dann können Sie es punktieren
und ins Labor schicken.
Es ist wichtig,
ob es blutig ist oder bernsteinfarben ist.
Es ist eine klare Acid sein.
Es muss ja nicht unbedingt,
nur weil der Patient auch Alkohol trinkt.
Es kann ja etwas anderes sein.
Das Acid ist manchmal verursacht.
Man muss darauf beachten.
Man muss darauf beachten,
dass es wichtig ist,
dass man es auch nicht mehr kann.
Es ist wichtig,
dass man es proben kann.
Zitäern haben Sie gesagt.
Magendarm-Spielungen haben Sie auch gesagt.
Was man auch machen sollte,
ist ein Ultraschall vom Herzen.
Es geht um eine Rechtsherzinsuffizienz.
Sie sind auch da?
Kein Problem.
Ich konnte nicht hören.
Sie können kurz auf das Herz
mit dem Ultraschall gucken.
Ob er eine Rechtsherzinsuffizienz hat?
Genau.
Ob er gestaut ist?
Er ist ein Insuffizienz.
Nehmen Sie den Patienten stationär auf?
Es hängt von der Diagnose
und seiner Blutwerte.
Natürlich ab.
Nach der Ergebnisse,
wenn er Zirose hat,
könnte man die Diagnose
aufnehmen.
Was machen Sie, wenn der Patient nicht bleiben möchte?
Noch mal bitte.
Er möchte nicht stationär bleiben.
Was machen Sie?
Natürlich zuerst müssen wir empfehlen.
Aber natürlich,
wir sind hier,
aber hier sind wir nicht gefänglich.
Wir müssen eine
Unterschrift erhalten,
wenn der Patient nach Hause gehen möchte
und der Patient
kann alles machen.
Was machen Sie, wenn er nicht unterschneidet?
eigentlich. Wo sind Sie die Polizei? Ja, ich weiß es nicht eigentlich. Was machen wir sonst?
Sie können nichts machen. Sie schreiben das auch, dokumentieren das, schreiben auf,
Patient und am besten ein Zeugen, vielleicht eine kranken Schwester oder einen anderen Arzt holen,
der das bezeugen kann. Verstanden? Ja, es ist zwei verschiedene Leute, zwei verschiedene Leute,
eine Bericht oder eine Wiege, kann man sagen. Nein, Sie können, wenn Sie einen Arztbogen
ausfüllen, dann können Sie das notieren, schreiben, der Patient möchte nicht stationär bleiben und geht
gegen Erzischen Rat. Er unterschreibt die Einglückung aber nicht und dann können Sie ihn krammern dazu
fügen. Zeuge ist Dr. Hans Schmidt oder kranken Schwester Annette oder so was, ne? Ist ganz wichtig.
Ja, natürlich. Falls er irgendwas passieren sollte, dann müssten Sie sich absichern. Ja,
natürlich. Aber Sie können kein Zwingen, was zu unterschreiben, es geht nicht. Gut, okay.
Vielen Dank. Ich bedanke mich bei Ihnen auch über diese Aufnahmegespiel.